wollte dieser mann seine frau umbringen
wir wissen es nicht klar ist bernhard w
verbrachte 814 tage in untersuchungs und
sicherheitshaft bevor ihn das
bezirksgericht erstinstanzlich
freisprach der berufungsprozess soll
voraussichtlich nächstes jahr
stattfinden
mit uns kehrte an den ort zurück an dem
er ohnmacht zwang und unrecht empfunden
hat married too sexy die papiertonne 3x
mit befragt alles was ich jemals in der
hand kam ausgewertet die person und das
wird und im urteil 54 sieht es trotzdem
nicht gemacht auch wenn die chancen
recht er hat ja denn die so dass man
ermittle das war nicht verstanden dass
man dafür 814 dass man die nicht
verstanden
[Musik]
und dass ich überhaupt keine rechte mehr
h&m hat gar nicht mehr
das verstand es regnet
[Musik]
die staatsanwaltschaft begründet die
lange haft aber damit dass bernhard w
deutscher und noch nicht lange in der
schweiz gewesen sei somit habe
fluchtgefahr bestanden
[Musik]
unsere geschichte beginnt im aargauer
fricktal
wir treffen bernhard w diesen sommer ein
gutes jahr nach seiner haftentlassung
hier lebt der diplomierte
umweltwissenschaftler zurzeit auf sich
allein gestellt ohne job ohne staatliche
unterstützung bernhard w versuchte im
alltag wieder klar zu kommen und ich bin
dankbar dass sie vor ihrem garten
business und methoden zu versorgen
wieso man in kalter ich ein ganzes für
das ja nicht viel zwischen 50 und 100
franken ohne dass man sagen das muss
lange
was war geschehen
am anfang steht ein vorfall anfang 2015
im haus des ehepaars die aussagen dazu
von bernhard weh und seiner frau gehen
diametral auseinander
in der anklageschrift der
staatsanwaltschaft rheinfelden steht
später bernhard w wird der versuchten
vorsätzlichen tötung beschuldigt in der
nacht vom 28
januar 2015 soll bernhard w versucht
haben seine frau mit einem kissen im
schlafzimmer zu ersticken
anschließend habe er mit beiden händen
in einem 15-minütigen kampf versucht den
mund und die nase der frau zu zu halten
seither ist in bernhard w s leben nichts
mehr wie es einmal war
bernhard b bestreitet die tat sei
aufgewacht die frau habe in panik
geschrien mit einem messer in der hand
zwei sie neben dem bett gesessen er habe
sie festgehalten
einen kampf habe es nie gegeben ein
albtraum für den 56 jährigen der zu dem
zeitpunkt nett und lustig bis jetzt mit
cannabis tony awards auch der
schwerwiegende vorwurf ja immer schwer
liegen der worte denn als kantonspolizei
gliederten sich seit dem erfolg vor
häuslicher gewalt hat das nicht
verstanden dass die mich meinte und
hongkong und die frage offen ist der
muss ins auto steige nicht zu ihrem
freund gefallen
ich bin nicht flüchtet politik macht und
das größte inszenierung für sie es gibt
keine spuren von rosi und schon gar
nicht mit der hand wie sie es seit einer
viertelstunde mit der hand ok einig was
die hand rollenden viertelstunde aber
spuren ist ok
bezirksgefängnis kulm zwei lange jahre
und drei monate verbringt bernhard w in
untersuchungs und sicherheitshaft ohne
rechte fühlt sich bernhard wie hier
belogen und betrogen vom rechtsstaat auf
anfrage von uns kehrt er zum ersten mal
an den ort seines grauens zurück
erinnerungen werden wach wie genau so
wie das historische und wenn ja ob sie
auf dem bett der nach dem nur halb
europa und hanni tor 12
meine und exegese gar nicht zwischen
zwei unterstützer sind ja zwei mann
unterzahl richter so wie damals am
anfang heute zum beispiel denkt hat man
global vor geistern oder hunden ein
wenn sie es schafft verrechnet und damit
ins verstanden aber nicht so sehr
privatsphäre
fehlanzeige heute noch fällt es den
gebürtigen deutschen schwer über das
erlebte zu reden
814 lange tage in haft für bernhard w
wie ein schlechter traum aus dem er
nicht mehr aufwachte
[Musik]
sn sie sich gedanken macht warum bin ich
da das habe ich gemacht dass ich nach
oben
das sind sie kennen das schon
der in u haft sitzt für den gilt die
unschuldsvermutung
trotzdem heißt u-haft hier 23 stunden
pro tag in der zelle eingesperrt zu sein
und eine stunde bewegung im verglasten
belüfteten spazieren
wir haben wichtige andere ist daher ein
herlaufen und welche stolz machen und
nehmen uns gefehlt dass er unschuldig
irgendwo ich das ist der volle druck und
das schaffen wir nur ein ei richtig der
beschuldigte das ist der name von der
person der beschuldigte sind die schuld
noch zu wiese und enes so in crange
schafft's halte dass er sich schuldig
fehlt von der ersten bis zur letzten
sekunde
die oberstaatsanwaltschaft ag
widerspricht diesem vorwurf
staatsanwaltschaft auftrag der ehre und
des sachverhalts ermittler dort wie die
belastung der in die entlastung
umständlich fertigt behandle das hammer
mit dem sinn in dem fall gemacht
ich kann aber nachvollziehen dass die
beschuldigte ein anderer persönlich nie
druck kommt
das gefängnis limmattal in dietikon
bietet 72 uhr haftplätze an für
erwachsene und jugendliche
gefängnisdirektor daniel bosshard zeigt
uns eine seiner zellen wäre bernhard w
hier gelandet hätte er nicht nur viel
mehr platz gehabt sondern auch sonst ein
ganz anderes u-haft regime erlebt wie
viel strom pro geständnis außerhalb von
der zahl also die ins haus wenn er alles
us-netz vor mir ihm anbietet hat
möglichkeit und quer sechster und ab der
kurse hält sie das haben wir auch machen
und erfahren auf den spazierhof gab die
gruppe voll zugang zwar einmal am tag
oder usa hat heute zahlen sie den kanal
dusche in der es sind ja und untersagt
und es ist den kantonen überlassen wie
sie ihre u-haft gestalten so ist es
möglich dass die situation im kanton
zürich ganz anders ist als im
nachbarkanton aargau bis hin zum
speziellen staatsanwälte hätten gerne
möglichst widriger haftbedingungen
seinen strafverteidiger um geständnisse
zu erzwingen
auch daniel kloiber leitender
staatsanwalt im kanton zürich wird immer
wieder in der u-haft werde mit druck
gearbeitet
was sagen sie zum vorwurf das hofft auch
wenn die als beugehaft missbraucht werde
also der vorwurf vor dem missbrauch wie
sich mit aller schärfe zurück
wenn man zurückschaut ist das allenfalls
so empfindet wird vorhanden bernhard w
auf dem weg zum bezirksgericht
rheinfelden wo der prozess gegen ihn
stattgefunden hat
im april 2017 ist er hier als
beschuldigter in handschellen den
strafrichtern vorgeladen worden
[Musik]
bernhard weh erinnert sich an die drei
intensiven verhandlungstage in diesem
saal erinnert sie sich
als der passant wurde als open access
freitag in dem stoff gerichtsprozess und
deutscher wald zu schützen und die boxer
hat er musik legt und hat er die fehler
und ist sehr aktuell fünf richterinnen
und richter und die recht schrieb er in
sechs personen vorm ende 32 anderthalb
meter ordner und polizisten hinter mehr
und dahinter ganzen lied mit freunden
und der schulklasse also viele zuschauer
und öffentlichen ja nicht rosig
denn habe gehört was staatsanwaltschaft
fordert
auch ihr hund
für versuchte vorsätzliche tötung und
beklagt frau hat durch ihre arbeit 14
jahre für mord der sächsische drittes
hätten eigentlich nämlich viel küsst
das seien ja richtig um kabel 14 wortes
worten einfache ring eine tonne verkauft
das bezirksgericht kommt erstinstanzlich
zum schluss aufgrund widersprüchlicher
und unglaubwürdiger aussagen sowohl auf
seiten von bernhard weh als auf seiner
frau kann vorliegend nicht auf einen
eindeutigen sachverhalt abgestellt
werden
gesamthaft würden erhebliche und nicht
zu unterdrücken der zweifel daran
vorliegen dass bernhard w seine frau
töten wollte in seinem urteil erkennt
das gericht deshalb bernhard w wird vom
vorwurf der versuchten vorsätzlichen
tötung freigesprochen
die sicherheits beziehungsweise
untersuchungshaft ist im nachhinein als
ungerechtfertigte zwangsmaßnahme zu
werten
bernhard w wird deshalb vom gericht eine
genugtuung von 120000 franken für die
814 hafttage zugesprochen
dann habe ich gehört dass ich
freigesprochen
ich glaube und denn
frau schützt vor allem von zuschauern
vor allem ist die usa hatten sie dürfen
als erstes wird ihre mal danke an all
die anderen menschen die einzig person
wohnaccessoires und den handschellen
angelegt und begrüßung wird unsere
gebäude user wenn in europe in anderen
gefängnissen
[Musik]
bewegt uns zentral klang ist dann haltet
ihr von militär einigen
[Musik]
entwickeln die sogenannte freiheit und
würde
[Musik]
freunde holen ihn ab danach ist bernhard
w auf sich allein gestellt
18 monate später lebt er hier in einer
möblierten ferienwohnung in der zutritt
zum gemeinsamen einfamilienhaus wird
bernhard w bis heute verwehrt
auch die genugtuungssumme von 120000
franken kriegt dann nicht da ehefrau und
staatsanwaltschaft den fall ans
obergericht weiterziehen
nur ein paar wenige kartonschachteln
bleiben ihm von der zeit vor der haft
vor
da nach dem ja auch nicht sein das ist
das was da steht und das was in den chor
steht bin vor ort möller ja das ist
stattdessen türmen sich die ordner mit
akten und rechnungen konnte russ
firmenkonto alles weg alles nicht mehr
leiter katar packard um das erkennen
dass dass es möglich ist dass man über
ein einfaches so alles wegnimmt ob rim
den gleichwohl rechnet zugeschickt
besser verzichtet interessant der
zürcher staatsanwalt kloiber sagt ihm
und seinen kollegen sei klar dass es um
existenzen geht
wir sehen durch bewusst nach und mit
einem lager krank machen
es ist nicht lustig war am morgen habe
sich nicht plötzlich polizei es hat wenn
man nach 24 stunden innere zahlen rückt
man sich noch rasch thematisiert auf aus
der u-haft und verrührt freunde wenden
sich vor allem an und biss mir das wort
braucht also sehr viel
aufgeklebt hat die untersuchungshaft als
härtestes zwangsmittel ein fachforum
menge marihuana
auch das zürcher amt für justizvollzug
ist sich der problematik bewusst
roland zurkirchen direktor der zürcher
u-haft gefängnisse ortet
verbesserungspotenzial
das war mir damit an dass alle
beteiligten die unschuldsvermutung ernst
nehmen müssten
ein widerspruch 2 steht es gilt die
unschuldsvermutung und wird um hofft
ausgestattet ist ja da geht's will muss
auf die stärke des die strategie die
stiere hofft form oder und mir da der
widerspruch überhaupt besiegen oder das
sicher dass ich einen von einer frau
geständige wo sich wird wie sie die
zukunft hat
aber es ist ja verständlich zumindest
stoßen
man lud in u haft setzte existenz völlig
vernichtet dramatisiert unterscheiden
versuche die sind tatsächlich schon für
mich ist das sehr stoßen oder und dem
sinn ist es ja so dass man das ich sage
das entspricht einem rechtsempfinden
oder im ihm mit meinem rechtsempfinden
rechtsgang kritisches oder dass das dass
er stand für straftaten begangen hat dem
sind straff sich einen richtig zeit hat
ja wohl eher die schule wurde
darum hat zurkirchen im kanton zürich
einen prozess angestoßen der
signalwirkung für die ganze schweiz
haben soll
die u haft wird grundsätzlich überdacht
ziel weniger sogenannte haft schäden
verursachen
der direktor des gefängnisses limmattal
hat den auftrag erhalten konkrete
maßnahmen zu formulieren und diese in
seinem haus umzusetzen
weil es wäre dann so die erste schritt
wird mache das müsst ihr unbedingt
märkischen scott weiter
also wir haben ja schon mit dem
täglichen kurze gruppe vollzug und
dusche ja nur zweimal in der woche noch
fünf mal in der woche
und jetzt ging sie denn irgendwann mal
darum dass man ruhe und ressource rettet
damit man das wirklich wie das
wochenende anbieten und auf die
tagesstunden nach jeder tag verlängert
den songs
[Musik]
bernhard w kämpft mit den folgen der
langen haft leidet an einer depression
und ist schwer traumatisiert und
trotzdem bemüht er sich in seinem
improvisierten büro um einen job
doch es folgen nur absagen
[Musik]
keine aber gar keine einkünfte name
mitteilt quelle nicht inzwischen hat ein
gericht die frau zu einer
unterhaltszahlung verpflichtet doch mit
anwaltskosten und rückzahlung der
darlehen bleibt davon nichts mehr übrig
bernhard w kämpft weiter einsam für
seine unschuld und sein recht versorger
das vom netz lösen wir nur die balance
netz verliere medizin versetzte auch
verstimmt mir von ihm soziale umfeld von
freier ganz wenige freunde so dass
nachher nicht nächstes jahr soll der
berufungsprozess stattfinden ist
bernhard wie täter oder opfer
wir wissen es nicht es gilt die
unschuldsvermutung
[Musik]